Wonder is defined as the vitality and appreciation
felt when one experiences something new and
transcending.
Something rich with revelation, progress,
and beauty.
Something that seems to causes time to cease
and life to absorb into your being, where
everything becomes clear and peaceful.
Life is synonymous with progression.
It is constantly accelerating towards something.
We do not know what, or even why, but we do
know that we are a part of it.
And all we want is to feel connected to it.
Just as we hate to be left out of social activities
with friends and family, we would hate even
more to be left out of the activity of life
itself.
As members of nature’s evolution, the most
enthralling and worthy pursuit is to experience
that which synchronizes us with its movement.
To experience something unfamiliar and advancing.
To touch the substance of life and realize
how connected we are to it.
Whether it is by continuously progressing
in something little by little, or by stepping
into an entirely new realm of possibility,
it is the associated wonder we feel that connects
us to life.
Anytime we achieve a new career goal, or learn
a new skill, or discover a new concept of
life.
Or even just by new exposure to the senses.
Like the first time we hear a song that brings
us to a harmonizing state of emotion that
we have never felt before.
Or the first time we see an animal in person
whose massive size is so unfathomable that
we feel as though we have been transported
to a different planet.
Or the first time we smell the lushness of
a tropical forest and it absorbs us into a
state of bliss.
These feelings of wonder, however big or small
they may be, are the essence of human life.
They are the fuel to our engines.
More than any pursuit of happiness or wealth
or fame, it is the pursuit of wonder that
truly brings us
to life.